Well, there’s a couple reasons why college
has gotten so expensive.
First of all is: states are cutting higher
education funding.
Second thing is: supply and demand.
What we have is a crisis where to get onto
the job ladder, the few decent jobs left—that
have healthcare, that have security, that
have a pension—they all require a college
degree.
So you have to go to college, basically.
And yet the actual number of spaces in colleges
hasn’t really increased.
Harvard admits something like ten percent
more now than they did in the ‘70s, so there
are more people competing for fewer spots.
And that means that the colleges can just
raise the price, and they’ll find somebody
to pay it.
No matter how high it gets, somebody is out
there paying it, and so they just raise it
and raise it and raise it, and we keep paying
it.
Colleges are adding services like rock climbing
gyms, extra administration, they’re doing
more marketing, they’re doing these really
expensive study abroad programs and, again,
they’re competing over the rich kids, they’re
competing over the ten percent and the one
percent, people who are not “cost sensitive.”
Colleges keep throwing services and throwing
bells and whistles at them, and they’re
just paying it, because the entire economy
is shifting toward marketing itself to the
top ten percent and the top one percent, and
those are the kids that are going to college
now.
The college premium (how much extra you earn
for going to college) is 70 percent.
You earn almost double if you go to college
on average than if you don’t go to college.
So we’re in this bind where you HAVE to
go to college or else you end up in a really
bad job for the rest of your life, but them
to go to college you have to go into $80,000,
$100,000, more than that debt.
I interviewed somebody for the article that
is paying off $311,000 in debt.
I interviewed another person who was actually
a bankruptcy lawyer who was paying $2000 a
month in student loans after he got out of
college.
And so when you look at how many of us have
student loans—and that we’re paying them
off at the time when we’re early in our
careers, we’re not as established in our
fields, we can’t afford decent housing,
we aren’t earning very much at that time,
and then we’re also, on top of that, paying
a couple hundred dollars a month extra—that’s
money we’re not saving, that’s money we’re
not putting to a pension, that’s money we’re
not putting to a home—and that extends the
period of—what our parents call “adolescence,”
but really, insecurity—that extends our
period of insecurity into our 30s and our
40s.
And so if you look at any poll of millennials,
more than half say they have put off marriage,
they have put off children, they have put
off buying a home because of their student
loans.
And student loans are the only form of debt
that you cannot get rid of in bankruptcy,
so they are literally inescapable.
Even if you die, in some states your partner
might actually have to pay them off for you.
So this is a ball and chain around the ankle
of millions of millennials, and again, it’s
not a choice that we made, it’s the economy
that we’re in, that to get onto the job
ladder you need to have an education.
One of the things that we forget, and especially
our parents forget, is how much cheaper college
used to be.
When my dad was in college he worked for ten
hours a week in the cafeteria, and that was
enough for his tuition and a little bit of
his rent.
That doesn’t sound familiar to anybody I
know.
And what has happened since then is: the cost
of education has gone up between 400 and 1200
percent depending on the kind of school you
go to.
Meanwhile, minimum wages haven’t really
budged, general wages haven’t really budged,
and the price of everything else has gotten
higher too.
So in the early ‘70s it took around 300
hours of minimum wage work to afford a four-year
education.
By the 2000s it took 4,400 hours of minimum
wage work to afford a four-year education.
There are a lot of really smart people who
look at a debt of $100,000 when they get out
and minimum payments of hundreds of dollars
every month and go, “It’s not worth it.”
And the problem is the economy really isn’t
working for them.
If you look at any measure of poverty, unemployment,
there’s never been a time in America where
it’s worse to not be a college graduate.
If you want a pension, if you want healthcare,
if you want decent wages, if you want security,
all of those jobs now require college degrees.
And even if they don’t require college degrees,
there’s now so many people with college
degrees they’re getting those jobs.
Right?
The hiring manager at a coffee shop looks
at two resumes and one has a college degree
and one doesn’t, even if the job doesn’t
necessarily require a college degree he’s
going to hire the college grad because he
thinks they’re smarter, harder working,
or whatever.
And so you’ve got kids that are now systematically
disadvantaged because they didn’t go to
college, but it’s understandable that they
wouldn’t want to given the cost.
And so we need to think about all of the opportunities
that we’re missing by having an entire generation
of people who look at the cost of college
and decide not to go, and what those people
could be doing if they went.
I don’t know if other people have noticed
this, but at my high school the rich kids
went to college and the smart kids went to
college.
And it feels like there’s this huge tranche
of kids that were sort of normal kids—they
weren’t exceptional—and those mediocre
kids, if they were rich they went to college,
and if they were exceptional and they weren’t
rich they went to college.
But that leaves out this huge structure of
all these millions of people who were just
kind of average but just didn’t go because
they ended up doing something else.
I think we as Americans forget that we’re
the only country where college costs this
much, and we’re the only developed country
without a functioning safety net.
It’s a lot better in other countries.
I actually went to graduate school TWICE in
Europe, because I couldn’t afford to go
in America.
And in lots of European countries it is free.
(Tell everyone you know.)
And a lot of other countries it’s really
cheap.
And many of the degrees are in English, and
those countries are run by adults.
They’re great.
Go there.
I also went to community college for two years.
Community college has a bad reputation for
no particular reason.
Community colleges are great.
So people should consider going to community
college and then transferring to a two-year
university.
There’s nothing wrong with that.
We’re all doing our best.
Find a cheap way that works for you, and if
you can get a visa to leave America and stay
left, then do that too.